it's not just affecting kids and
teenagers
Mr Beast is probably the biggest YouTube
channel
his videos get tens of millions hundreds
of millions of views
Mr BEAST's sidekick
is a guy named Chris Tyson
sorry was a guy named Chris Tyson I
don't say that because he's dead I say
that because he says he's no longer a
guy
Chris Tyson is 26 years old
and he has just decided that he is
secretly a woman
Chris Tyson has made all sorts of jokes
about transvestites and transgenderism
and he's mocked the idea of it before
now
he says I am transgender I am a woman
all all fun and games right we kind of
giggle at it I I pity everyone who falls
into this
confusion
but this is even worse because Chris
Tyson is married and has a two and a
half year old child
and he just woke up one day told his
wife didn't tell his kid I assume
because the kid's probably just starting
to talk but told his wife yeah I'm
I'm not going to be your husband anymore
because I'm I'm going to be your wife or
something I'm a woman now
sorry Sonny I'm not Daddy anymore I'm
Mommy now or I'm something else but I'm
not Daddy whatever that is
and he's catching a lot of flack for
this online
now in response to that Chris Tyson has
said informed content
hormone replacement therapy saved my and
many others lives the hurdle gender
non-conforming people have to jump
through to get life-saving gender
affirming Health Care as a first world
in a first world country is wild to me
just let people make informed decisions
about their own bodies
in a first world country as if they have
these kinds of Therapies in non-first
world countries
a lot of these in Zambia okay I don't
think there's a lot of hormone
replacement therapy going on in Namibia
okay but
he says this is absolutely shocked this
is life-saving treatment
this is the line I always use and this
is the line that the teachers and the
doctors use to guilt parents and and
initiate them into the transgender cult
is they'll say well would you rather
have a dead son or a living daughter
that's yeah you got a trans your kid you
got to trans your son and drop off his
genitals and put him put him into onto
all these hormones to make them look a
little bit more like a girl because if
you don't he's going to kill himself and
it's going to be your fault it's a
life-saving treatment there is no
evidence of that there is no evidence
that the transgender transition
alleviates
anxiety depression suicidality although
to the contrary there is lots of
evidence that the transgender transition
exacerbates the sort of stresses and
despair that people are feeling before
they go into it we covered those studies
on the show last week
but furthermore put that aside for a
second with this guy
Chris Tyson
the problem here
highlights a broader problem within
liberalism within all of modern
political thought
which is we think about politics from
the perspective of what we can do it's
like Jurassic Park I know we can do this
stuff but did you ever think if you
should do this kind of stuff
we think of it from the perspective of
entitlements and we call those rights
even when they're they're things that
are manifestly wrong we still
preposterously call those wrong things
rights which is crazy because
wrongs cannot be rights it's right there
in the word writes regardless
it's not a good way to look at politics
a better way to look at politics a
better way to look at your own identity
is not from the perspective of Rights
and entitlement but from the perspective
of obligation not what you are owed but
what you owe to other people the reason
what this guy is doing publicly is wrong
is because he has an obligation to his
wife to be her husband
let's just say for a second that he
could change his sex and gender but he
can't but let's just say he could there
were some perfect surgery out there that
changed all of his DNA it changed all of
his features I mean that still wouldn't
change his Central identity but again
let's just let's just go for it he still
would have no right to do it
he took a vow to be her husband he has a
role he has a job to do he has a duty
and by neglecting that Duty he is
committing a grave Injustice against his
wife
then think about his kid
he owes it to his kid to be that kid's
father
that's his role that's his job that's
his duty
he doesn't have the right
to shirk that Duty
in pursuing his sexual fetish
he is denying his son
what his son is owed namely
a father
that's wrong and we we all do this
we don't we don't all go trans but but
we
all in Modern Life we we tend to shirk
our duties
we say oh who cares about my community
who cares about the common good oh who
cares about my family oh who cares and
we we make everything so cold and clean
and clinical and individualistic it's
not just the life that does that it's
the right that does that too
and you see this reflected in no fault
divorce
you see this reflected in the the
weakening of the American family even
between Generations
you see this in the below replacement
birth rate
you see this in the lack the the total
loss of of Civic
life and responsibility
we just forget our obligations
but we all have obligations
to our duty now I mentioned
that this guy just at age 26 one day
decided okay I'm gonna I'm gonna become
a woman
where does this come from
we talk about how well maybe it's just
this mental health condition called
gender dysphoria or we say well maybe
it's it's a true identity that they've
been just suppressing their whole lives
or we say well maybe now because it's
out there in the culture people are more
open-minded to it and they consider what
they previously hadn't even considered
which is a little more plausible than
the biological explanation but there's
one explanation that people aren't
really talking about
that I actually have to go to feminist
websites like the feminist current to
see anybody talking about which is
porn
according to many writers
according to many people who have looked
into this who've looked into this a lot
more closely than I have porn is playing
a huge role in The Surge of
transgenderism we know that porn is
ubiquitous in the culture unless you are
actively pursuing a discipline not to
look at pornography and you are a man
chances are you are looking at
pornography in this culture porn rates
or among men are like over 90 percent or
something in the age at which young men
are exposed to this is I on average I
think 11 and that's an older statistic I
think it's actually declined since then
so feminist current writes why isn't
anyone talking about the influence of
porn on the trans trend
in recent years trans pornography has
soared in popularity according to
pornhub's metadata both trans and
transgender porn searches have more than
quadrupled in the three years between
2014 to 2017 and by 2018 trans was
ranked the fifth highest search term of
the year
now I was informed of this a few years
ago by a reporter colleague of mine here
at the daily wire who said Michael have
you heard about this kind of transgender
porn called hypnosis porn and I said
nope haven't heard about that one tell
me about it and she had gone on some
deep dive hadn't watched it but had had
read about it and
she said it's this kind of pornography
where when people fall into it it just
totally scrambles their brain more so
than even other kinds of pornography and
it can lead to a rapid onset feeling of
gender dysphoria
they said okay well uh I'm curious I
don't want to look up the porn for a
couple reasons one because that that
would be wrong to do and I don't want to
expose myself to that and I don't want
to then have to you know not I have to
miss lunch the next day so I can go to
confession you know it's just it's a
busy week so I didn't want to do that
but I did look through
forums of people talking about this and
articles in places like feminist current
and
the way people write about this genre of
porn is terrifying I remember I don't
remember the exact book but there was a
guy who said I fell into this porn in my
40s I was a totally normal guy I fell
into this genre of porn within something
like two years I couldn't get the idea
of becoming a woman out of my head it's
ruined my life another person said that
it seemed like a military-grade
psychological weapons I thought oh my
goodness I don't even when I'm reading
about this kind of porn I try to I don't
want too many details because it seems
like it's really really potent and it
would probably help to explain the
shocking surge in transgender identity
unless there's just something in the
water that's turning all the freaking
Zoomers trans
the frog is gay but the Zoomer is trans
then
probably there's something to do with
this if your view of sexuality is being
totally transformed and that phenomenon
is coinciding with everybody looking at
increasingly crazy pornography there
might be a connection there this is this
is what one person said in according to
the feminist current article quote I
started watching transporn initially
five or so years ago and I remember I
had post-orgasm regret so you know he
finished looking at the poor and doing
whatever he's going to do and then he he
felt uh shame at that which is a good
feeling to feel if you when you do
something bad but he says back then I
imagine myself as the guy about a year
and a half ago I started to imagine the
possibility of being the girl in these
scenarios I wanted to be
I'll clean up a little bit of the
language here I was turned on by the
submissiveness of it he says then he
goes on this has led me to have some
gender dysphoria as I would love to be
the woman and see where that would take
me in my life as a fully transition to
trans woman too long didn't read my
sexual and gender identity has been
completely flipped on its head because
of this hypnotism type porn
all of which is to say
the the White House has just declared
that the covid pandemic is over oh good
that's good I'm glad I'm sure you can
all breathe a sigh of relief I know that
you were on the edge of your seats
worried staying up at night because you
were so worried about the covid pandemic
we were told for years that kovid was
the greatest Public Health crisis in the
country
porn is by far the biggest Public Health
crisis in the country and it's the one
that no one's allowed to talk about no
one who objects to it is allowed to
bring it up
and the ruling regime
pushes it on everybody the ruling regime
defends porn broadly on Free Speech
grounds which porn has never been
defended on Free Speech grants for the
whole history of our country until very
recently and the whole history of our
civilization until very very recently
it's obscene material obscenity is now
protected by Free Speech laws but
they're going further they're pushing
the porn in libraries and pushing the
porn in elementary schools it's a very
powerful tool to control people it's a
powerful tool to degrade people
when one looks at porn one has the
reaction that this guy has looking at a
very extreme and particularly degrading
form of porn but it's the same reaction
it's a kind of a shame
elsewhere in the feminist current
article
someone said that the very Act of
looking
looking at pornography is degrading and
so this uh humiliating and hypnotic type
of porn is a kind of metapornography
that it's a pornography about
what it is to view pornography and it it
can take you to really really weird
places now I've tried to well I've tried
to speak in vager terms about this one
because mercifully I haven't seen it so
I can't really speak to the details but
two because I don't I don't want to Peak
anybody's curiosity this is powerful
powerful stuff according to pretty much
everyone who's come into contact with it
and everyone who's doing research on it
and
it would seem clearer to me is leading
to lots of terrible effects on public
health and little little kids are being
exposed to it and we're just Dilly
dallying we're doing nothing about that
we're worried about covid oh no the kid
might catch a cough which statistically
won't do anything to him
what about that if you've got if you've
got something warping people's minds
that has the objective of degrading
people
and you degrade and humiliate a whole
people how are you supposed to have a
great country we're about to enter
the membrane segmentum the member block
here baby the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it I think
I'm a member use code knowlescana WLS
check out for two months free
on all annual plan this daily wire.com
Knowles see you there
foreign
[Music]